when Jeannie the sister the snarky
sister comes in to me in the office and
it's late in the film and and so she
says is mr. Rooney in and I said no he's
not young lady or something like that
and and she then she gives me big lip
and turns on her heel and flounces out
and then I just looked down at my desk
and I'm looking at a piece of my friend
I just say a little [ __ ] I'm not
sure what I said but it's it was rude so
many of you if you're John Hughes fans
know that he was a very fast writer and
there's sort of legends of how fast he
wrote in there they're all true so I'll
tell a quick story about how this came
to be he was in a deal of paramount and
the chairman of paramount was pressuring
him you gotta give us a script you gotta
give us a script because they're that
year was nineteen eighty-five there was
a threat of a strike a writer's strike
and if he didn't turn in the script that
he was going to direct he wouldn't be
able to to shoot it the strike never
happened but they didn't know that and
the we were in he was in pre-production
on pretty in pink which was just about
to start shooting and so he didn't have
his script ready he couldn't go and he
didn't any told Ned Tanana the time the
shred of an idea like Ferris Bueller I
got an idea by could it takes a day off
from school yeah it was a big fan who
said like okay whatever I was like that
sounds great and London night he was
being pressured by how he toys she was
directing pretty in pink to do the final
rewrites on that script which John hated
doing rewrites he mostly wrote as he was
going along so how he said I'm coming
over to your house I'm going to stay
there all night well do the rewrites and
then you'll give it to me you'll be done
and you can off and do your own thing so
comes over to John's house and gentlemen
night I worked all night long usually
that's when he wrote so how I discussed
it he went upstairs he said okay just
wait down here how I let me go to work
how he falls asleep on his couch about
midnight John works all through the
night light comes up in the living room
John comes downstairs at six in the
morning how he wakes up he's on a cup of
coffee and says hey this is great gotta
read this because did you do my rewrites
he said no no no but read this and it
was the first 50 pages of Ferris Bueller
then he got excited about the idea and
he wrote it and how I said okay and he
read it and he said this is a great join
you got to finish and he finished it in
three days turned it into the studio in
the studio greenlit the movie I actually
did add a line to John's script in that
first audition because it ended the
photos and buzzes we be bigger than all
their yeah they all adore him is the way
the line ended and because i like the
Chicago accent I thought it would be
good to say they can keep the righteous
dude and nobody said John just kinda
grim and I had a good feeling about it
even and it was just a wonderful working
situation